you also
you mentioned in one of your articles or
many of your articles that you dislike
faith
now do you see anything i i i
that that's a probably an um slightly
mischaracterization
it's not that i dislike it um
maybe i like it it's just that i don't
have it
okay okay so you don't have faith do you
see any
aspects of faith in the answer that you
can't be shaken from your
beliefs about whether or not there's one
answer to a question yes or no
once again what i'm saying is one answer
to it i'm not saying that i know
what each side of those answers are now
uh i am saying that when we define
the um the structure of of the
of the answer there is one way to define
that structure
even if parts of it have uncertainty or
however
you you want to to deal with it however
you you define that
there is ultimately an answer to those
those questions
it is that you can that you can
phrase um you know the issue of faith
is in a different kind of category um
uh you know faith is is a belief in
something the evidence may be
of which you don't see and in
various religions uh that is a virtue
and i i see it as a virtue and
i admire people who have it doesn't mean
i think it's either correct or that
i uh want it maybe i would want it but i
i don't have it the way
many people have faith um
when i'm talking about my
belief that there are ultimate answers
to these questions even if we can never
even define what that is
uh i i don't think that that's a a a
i wouldn't characterize that as faith
although
it's it's it is part of my belief system
and you know happy to question it